hey youtubers is Charlie so this week
orphan black went a little No Country
for Old Men mrs. s is not to be trusted
and we got a whole bunch of new
information about what the proletheans
are up to things are not looking very
good for Helena either if you're finding
me for the first time I'm just doing
weekly videos for each new episode of
orphan black season 2 be sure to
subscribe to get everything and please
ask me as many questions as you can
think about because sometimes it is so
hard to follow but that is actually one
of the things that I really like about
it it makes it so much more fun to talk
about so careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet but let's
start with top 5 moments and then I'll
do my review trust me I have as many
questions as you do so here we go number
5 Cosima gets her new lab of all the
clones right now I feel like Cosima is
doing the best job of being a spy or a
double agent however you want to think
about it Allison is just starting to
deal with the monitor Donnie's situation
but I think that will mostly be a
relationship comedy I always get really
excited for Cosima lab scenes because
that's where we get a lot of clone facts
like being fertile or not being fertile
as is the case with everyone except for
Sarah did anyone see how much that upset
Rachel whenever they talked about that I
can't wait to learn more of her
backstory and it looks like she'll be
working with Cosima and Delphine's so
I'm predicting their lab scenes in the
next couple of episodes will actually be
my favourites even if they don't drop a
lot of WTFs I also thought it was really
strange that Rachel did not know that
Cosima is a lesbian but let me know in
the comments below
what is the most interesting thing about
her number for Donnie is the monitor I'm
calling it now this is going to be one
of the most fun things about season 2
but Christian broomed the actor had this
interview that they played during one of
the ads and he talked about how much fun
it was to play Donnie is this silly
husband character and it was a big plus
for us is the audience that we were
getting to watch him do all this funny
monitor stuff now but not so much for
Donnie himself it kind of looks like
Alison's probably gonna end up stabbing
him a few times it seems like their plot
is gonna be this funny mr. and mrs.
Smith thing you know where it's like two
secret agents trying to get each other
that don't know that the other person
knows that they know I'm really
interested to see what's gonna happen to
Alison now that Felix is bailed on her
it looks like she's getting really
really isolated and I think she's gonna
end up doing some crazy stuff like
she'll slowly lose her mind snap and do
some hell on a level damage after a few
you know shopping trips remember she's
the clone with the access to all the
drug
in all the weapons I don't think it's
going to be too long before we see some
fireworks go off because in the teaser
for the next episode she's drinking a
lot number three orphan black road trip
so not only is Felix bailing on Alison
but Sara and Kyra can't trust mrs. s and
the proletheans are involved now too so
it's like all the clones are slowly
being separated like clone Club is gonna
be on hiatus temporarily based on the
teaser for episode 3 it looks like
Sarah's taking them to Cal's house the
idea the proletheans being sciency but
old-timey without a lot of tech kind of
fits somatically with Cal's character so
I like that I feel like as Sara deals
with project Leda and mrs. s she's gonna
be camping a lot in the woods for at
least a few episodes the cow stuff is
gonna be a little bit strange because
the actor who plays him also plays
Daario on Game of Thrones and that airs
like literally the next day so they're
so close together it gets a little bit
confusing in the fandom part of my brain
but the actor is great so it's gonna be
a lot of fun but I'm gonna have to start
making charge to keep track of everyone
number to mrs. s and the birdwatchers I
love how much of a badass she was in
this episode but I'm guessing that based
on the proletheans involvement the
birdwatchers
aren't gonna continue to be a big threat
I do kind of wonder how the proletheans
found out that the birdwatchers had Kira
I mean someone would have had to told
them about that I do think mrs. S was
being truthful when she said she's
always been on their side you know big
asterisk being though that she's not
saying which faction she really belongs
to if it's not the birdwatchers it seems
like she grew up with them but because
they double-crossed her I'm calling her
like her own rogue faction right now you
know somewhere between the neolutionists
in the proletheans who also kind of saw
the parallel between young mrs. s
running guns and Sarah selling drugs to
earn money I think the big takeaway from
all that mrs. s stuff is that now we
know there are people in London that
have answers about what's going on with
Kira's biology it is strange to think
that we went from having like you know
two big factions to like four more in
the span of a few minutes I'll say it
again I definitely feel like we need to
start keeping a flowchart to keep track
of everyone this season somebody feel
free to post a link in the comments if
you're actually doing that on tumblr
right now and my number one moment the
proletheans are going to try to breed
Helena hands down creepiest moment in
the episode they did not explicitly say
it but during that whole No Country for
Old Men murder all that talk about Helen
conceiving kind of foreshadowed they're
creepy Cylon plan to breed her seriously
if you didn't see it there was actually
an episode of Battlestar Galactica where
Starbuck gets captured by like a Cylon
doctor they tries to turn her into like
this creepy baby machine it potala in
this really interesting place this
season I think she's actually gonna end
up being one of my favorite clones
because she is super crazy and yeah you
know she killed a ton of people
including her own clones but now she's
being subjected to this really awful
creepy cult so I feel like we're gonna
wind up empathizing with her but let me
know if you agree this is actually a
pretty big question because Talon has
been a pretty big villain do you think
that we're gonna wind up sympathizing
with her because she's a victim now of
these crazy proletheans and be sure to
let me know what is your biggest
question after this episode you know
personally I'm really wondering who
those people in London are one of my
favorite moments that didn't necessarily
make my top 5 was Allison song blood
buddies let's actually hope that makes
it onto the DVD don't you feel like if
Allison does not get to perform that
play you know full-on this season they
should at least release it as a bonus
feature that would just be amazing
overall I gave the episode a B you know
I really enjoyed it not quite as much as
the premiere but I felt like the pacing
was a little bit uneven
especially with everyone kind of
scattering to the four winds sometimes
it can get a little confusing you know
when the different clones switch the
energy that they bring to each scene
like you know Allison is normally meant
to be the comedian and Cosima is like
the rational brain of the group so
whenever Cosima starts being funny in a
scene next to an Allison funny scene it
throws me off just a little bit and it
kind of seems like that's where the show
is taking them at least in the next
couple of episodes clone club did get a
whole bunch of new phones though so
expect a whole lot more conference calls
because they're not going to be in
physical proximity for a while and based
on what mrs. S was saying eventually
Sarah is gonna have to go to London or
they're gonna have to bring someone from
London to her let me know if you agree
though do you think that Sarah is going
to travel to London to learn more about
Keira or do you think that Mrs S is
going to bring someone from London to
Sarah it's like that old saying you know
bring Mohammad to the mountain or bring
the mountain to Mohammed I guess we just
don't know what the mountain is in this
case right now so next week I'll post my
episode 3 video after the episode airs
be sure to subscribe to get it
and don't forget new Game of Thrones
tomorrow so whole lot of Daario going to
be happened
this season it'll be funny right now
click here to get my episode 1 video and
click here to catch up on Game of
Thrones thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you